today Yanni anime zone a first
impression of the most epic show of this
spring season attack on Titan sorry
sorry wrong reckoning as I've stated
numerous times before I don't usually
watch seasonal shows my fear of finding
something amazing cuz when happens a lot
to think of it as something similar to
drag in a great session of sex over a
twenty six week period you get reeled in
at the beginning with this amazing
looking show who flashes you with just a
little bit of the potential she has you
start the session and it's exciting as
hell it feels like a first time again
but as soon as you get your rhythm going
BAM the sessions over you didn't come
and you have to wait another week to
continue again after an agonizing week
of waiting and anticipating you start
again it takes a little time to get into
again because it's been a while but as
soon as you're really into it it [ __ ]
ends again this process repeats for
about twenty six weeks with some weeks
having the ups and downs but because it
might have a shitty ending you don't
even know if you'll get to climax
correctly and wait where was I going
with this
oh yeah attack on Titan attack on Titan
or shingeki no kyojin was one of the
most anticipated shows of 2013 with
quite a bit of hype surrounding it
before it even started and now that the
first few episodes have aired the hype
Nev was growing so high that has blasted
off from the earth past the over 9000
market is probably orbiting somewhere in
interstellar space so as someone who has
been through enough hype over my years
of watching anime I approach this with a
lot of caution and after watching the
first four episodes I can safely say
that oh my god this is gonna be the best
anime ever I mean what I meant to say
was oh my god this is gonna be the best
on a serious note though no matter how
the rest of the series turns out I
personally thought that attack on Titan
has one of the strongest stars I've seen
in anime there I said it when a
seemingly brainless new species who hunt
and eat humans take over the earth
humanity is pushed to the verge of
extinction leads up to a main character
Eren to swear vengeance against all
these Titans for killing his own mother
the Titans are massive creatures who
look like oversized people without
clothes so it warrants the name attack
on Titan probably as much as it warrants
the name invasion of the giant stupid
naked people so it doesn't really matter
because of the apparent originality the
hype says the show has since the idea of
giant monsters terrorizing humanity is a
notion so original that has never ever
ever been done before
but more interestingly it takes a very
simple concept and builds an entire
world around it the primal fear what
would happen if humanity is no longer at
the top of the food chain and how the
world itself would change because of
that so far the show's done a great job
of building an entirely new world where
the rules have completely changed it may
sound like a very simple premise but
every episode has kept things
interesting and is also great excuse for
what looks like some spectacular looking
action sequences where they fight the
Titans because honestly who wouldn't
want to see an army of medieval Spider
Men flying around building slicing up
giant man-eating zombies I'll just pause
for a second to let the awesomeness of
that last sentence sink in so far the
weakest element I can possibly see is
the characters especially the main
character Aaron who may seem the tad
cliche with the whole swearing vengeance
and his only job thus far is complaining
that people don't seem to give enough
[ __ ] but honestly I don't mind for now
since the events of the first episode
was so powerful but I can't blame him
for having this cliched conviction the
horrific scene at the end of episode 1
had a bigger emotional impact on me than
most anime do in their entire run and
from then on I was immediately invested
into the whole show though it's also a
good sign when the females are just
blobs of fanservice meat and seemingly
have personalities with the [ __ ] that
uh did I miss anything else worth noting
that [ __ ] opening currently attack on
titan simulcasting every week on control
and Funimation you can also go to
country order calm sake anime zone for a
free two weeks of premium membership
where you can watch this [ __ ]
and now I'll have to wait 20 or so weeks
when I do a full review to see if I'll
be eating these words that are coming
out of my mouth but at the moment attack
on Titan is doing little wrong and has
pretty much everything going for it it's
high production values massive potential
an interesting concept makes it a must
watch for this spring season but I'm
sure everyone already is anyway so maybe
I'm just being [ __ ] redundant at this
point
well the hype surrounding it now though
it's got to do a lot of things wrong for
it to die down because as we know from
experience with a star so strong and the
limitless potential in the plot there's
no possible way that they could ever
[ __ ] it up oh go [ __ ] yourself already
hey guys geek okay I hope you enjoyed
the first impression I'm sorry there's
not a new review or rant but I've been
really busy working on a bridge to
episode 3 and fall and another review so
that might take a bit more time to come
out so I just want to get some kind of
video out if you're new here though want
to check out my other stuff and you if
you really like it why not give me a
subscribe maybe or you can maybe find me
on Facebook or Twitter in the
description below but anyway for the
rest of you I just wanted to say no I'm
not dead I'm still working on the videos
and I hope yes more out soon so until
then it's been gigging and I'll see you
all next time